make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and we are picking back up again
with the conclusion of
spider-man yes we are we are wrapping up
the spider-man event
uh and this is probably the single most
important part of the story not
necessarily because of what's happened
so far but because of the future
of miles morales so what we end up doing
here is we initially pick up with
mysterio
and mysterio is suffering from the same
problem that every super villain suffers
from
stupidity so the idea behind this with
mysterio
[Laughter]
so the idea behind this with mysterio is
that he comes to the realization
that he actually unintentionally
defeated spider-man that with spider-man
being whisked off into this other
dimension where peter parker in that
reality is dead
that it leaves no spider-man in this
universe right in the main marvel
universe there is no peter parker here
right he's
off in the ultimate universe somewhere
and it was something that mysterio
had not really thought of before and now
he realizes it like man dude okay
like i actually defeated spider-man but
then the question becomes why isn't it
enough
right like why is it not enough he's
like i have to see it right i have to
see him suffer and die i'll just take a
peek for myself just for one moment now
this is brian michael bendis being brian
michael bendis if it were me writing the
story it would be like oh man dude i won
cool the end and that would be it right
it would be mysterio realizing he
basically got the upper hand on peter
parker and there's no no more spider-man
here such as it is
dennis wanted to tell the story and so
so basically mysterio comes to the
realization that he wants to actually
see spider-man suffer and die and so he
reopens he
basically reactivates the portal and
takes a peek inside only for webbing to
come flying out
and the big ship basically attach itself
to him and then of course you have peter
parker you have miles morales and the
ultimates team who's there right the
ultimate avengers who are all there and
it's kind of like well crap
right like well damn like that's that's
basically it right like okay
i mean who could have possibly seen that
coming the cool thing about this though
is that one thing to understand with
mysterio is he's usually always got an
ace up his sleeve and that's one of the
things that makes him so dangerous
right and so where you have nick fury
you've got the rest of the guys who are
kind of like cool the day
saved keep in mind they're not used to
the kind of villains you have in the
main marvel universe where somehow they
always have some kind of an escape plan
or something like that remember the main
marvel universe is a lot less realistic
than the ultimate universe was and so
mysterio
immediately types away and just starts
releasing a whole host of these
chemicals and sets off an explosion and
when that happens
basically everybody here like iron man
nick fury miles morales all these
various guys are met by what are
essentially their worst nightmares right
it's literally what they're exposed to
using the power
of mysterio he exposes all of them to
their worst nightmares right so you've
got all the ultimates who are dead at
the hands of tony stark which of course
is definitely an allusion to what we saw
in the marvel cinematic universe uh
you've got nick fury who's watching the
world on fire watching the world burn
green goblin has killed aunt may in the
eye
in front of i'm sorry really dr octopus
and green goblin have killed on may in
front of spider-man and then you've got
the prowler who killed
uh miles morales mother and father and
so because of that where everybody else
is kind of succumbing to this
miles sort of succumbs to it a little
bit but then
manages to get the upper hand on it even
if only for a moment and when that
happens he realizes mysterio's making a
break for the portal and he tackles
mysterio now by all standards of
measurement
miles should have should have been 100
incapacitated here and again
that's kind of the critique of bendis
right dennis is just well of course
miles morales has to be on top he's the
guy that i'm riding right now he's the
main spider-man we can't have him lose
right so it's kind of like okay you know
it's sort of you just kind of go with it
in this story right it's just kind of
the way that bendis does it but where
you end up having mysterio who of course
uses powers on miles yet again he almost
gets the upper hand
miles dodges the attack goes invisible
and the mysterio trying to figure out
what happens
ends up being attacked by miles again
now again this has kind of been
basically saying like this is how
capable miles is now the reality of this
is that while this was kind of i
wouldn't say far-fetched but kind of
like what in the world's going on here
you know back in the day in this day and
age it's
common practice and it kind of makes
sense i think that with this story and
and miles being able to overcome
mysterio so
fast despite mysterio's abilities was
really more of just bendis wanting to
tell the story as opposed to just kind
of letting it play out organically
in reality having somebody like mysterio
was probably not the best bet they
probably should have been somebody more
like dr
octopus because mysterio's powers are
not limited to just some kind of
tentacles attached to his back that go
after you then he messes with your mind
he messes with your head and so there
isn't really a whole lot of reason to
believe that miles would somehow be able
to overcome this
so quickly right if you're trying to
maintain that kind of comic book lore
that we're used to and kind of maintain
consistency
then you know it's something you would
kind of expect but with peter parker
able to overcome it as well alongside
miles they take out mysterio
pretty quickly right he's defeated
pretty fast and so from that point what
they end up doing is actually keeping
mysterio
inside the ultimate universe and the
reason why is because mysterio now
knows that peter parker's spider-man and
so it kind of creates this situation
where peter's like okay cool yeah man
hold on to him i appreciate it guys
thanks for looking out it's kind of a
shady thing to do but
this is really the most important moment
that comes out of this right which is
why we kind of
more or less ham-fisted our way through
this there's a point where peter and
miles are talking and
peter basically thanks him for keeping
the legacy of spider-man going and when
miles asks him like does that mean that
i have your blessing peter's like
absolutely this was brian michael bendis
giving a big middle finger to the
naysayers and we talked about that
before that when miles first showed up
there were a lot of people who were
really pissy about the fact that peter
parker and the ultimate universe had
been killed and they wanted they didn't
want miles they wanted peter parker the
response of bendis is
you already have peter parker you've had
him for like 50 years right you've had
peter parker for a long long time
you need to get over yourselves right
it's time for a new spider-man it's time
to kind of continue on this story
focusing on somebody else we can't do
that in the main marvel universe because
peter parker is etched in stone
forevermore
the spider-man in the main marvel
universe we can't change that marvel
editorial won't let me change it and
even if i wanted to it'd be a terrible
idea to do it anyway but in the ultimate
universe i created this character
vendors giveth bendis take it
and take it away and that's kind of his
that's kind of his stance on that and so
when you had a lot of people who were
giving him flack and really complaining
a lot on the the various form boards and
social media different things like that
about miles morales taking over the role
of spider-man in the ultimate universe
this was really been to saying no he's
not going anywhere right if what you
expected me to do was to basically
give in acquiesce and admit defeat and
say hey you know you
you 50 comic book fans who sound like 5
million obviously you guys don't like
miles morales so let me just get rid of
him and bring back peter parker if
that's what you were expecting then i'm
sorry you're gravely mistaken that's
not what's going to happen and so we
ended up just getting miles more alice
going forward and so it's one of these
things where with with miles kind of
getting the official blessing
of peter parker that you have this
moment where nick fury kind of pulls him
aside and says
you got his blessing man like you earned
it kid right if that spider-man the real
true spider-man gives you his blessing
then you're good right just go forward
and do your superhero thing so it's
really not anymore nick fury kind of
questioning miles anymore kind of
looking at him with a skewed eye or
really the only eye he can look at him
at
uh look at him with and just kind of you
know it's just one his one good eye kind
of looking at him with a skewed eye and
then just kind of being like
is he really gonna be a good spider-man
at this point you know he kind of goes
forward with a whole new level of
confidence that he didn't really have
before
and that's kind of a cool thing because
what you do is you switch over to peter
parker himself
back home right back in his own
apartment he's like miles more house
miles morales i wonder if we have a
miles morales in the main marvel
universe and then it ends now
of course we know as far as i'm aware
that's not true
in in marvel comics right this story was
told like eight years ago so we know
that's not really true
at the time this was written everybody
wanted to know if it was true or not it
was like the biggest
biggest cliffhanger of like a decade
right like i wonder if it's real i
wonder if they really do have a miles
more house in the main marvel universe
and it's like i wonder what's gonna
happen with that right it's kind of
crazy but it is a cool story let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section did you guys enjoy spiderman the
very first story
the very first time where peter parker
and miles morales meet one another let
me know what you guys think i'm kind of
curious
what your all stance is but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
you